the question was have i asked people in
this room if they've felt as though some
violence has been committed on them no i
haven't asked because no violence has
been committed on you because violence
is not a subjective feeling violence is
an objective fact
i can objectively gauge whether or not
someone has become violent the other day
i was at the university of missouri
kansas city some protester attacked me
with some weird chemical that was an
objective act of violence but somebody
disagreeing with me such as some people
in this room are doing are not
committing violence on me this is the
foundation of liberal education if you
cannot understand that there is a
difference between speech and violence
you don't understand anything that
undergirds the liberal arts or liberal
education if our teachers don't under
understand the difference between ideas
and violence between speech and violence
then they are in no position to educate
the next generation of americans
[Applause]